Canadian food who took his eye
chinese-inspired look like an angry dad
who's been watching Fox News for too
long wherever we are
welcome to debatable the show where we
subject ourselves to stupid trivial
arguments so you don't have to now look
I'm not a religious man but pizza that's
a little slice of heaven on earth isn't
it a hot perfect symphony of flavors and
textures delicately dancing across your
tongue and down your gullet oh but
there's a pizza storm brewing folks and
based on your gut reaction to the
following phrase you'll know your stance
on the issue Hawaiian pizza now some
would argue that its culinary evolution
others that it's a brazen affront to an
already perfect dish are we gonna reach
a resolution here nope let's have at it
though Hawaiian pizza it's debatable
[Music]
propyne mmm yeah
let me tell you pineapple Patrick those
pineapples belong on this pizza we don't
need to live in this box of pepperoni
and only sausage yeah I'm all for it
like getting variants in your life
experiences I just want to you know
filter out the shitty ones what are two
things that you would say like huh that
doesn't really go together maybe a man
on the moon you know what else didn't
belong together at one point Oreos and
peanut butter Chuck and Blair yes the
dynamic duo of tomato and pineapple
everyone knows they go together like
this it's science
it's a ver no it's not sorry you know
what the thing about peanut butter and
Oreos are you don't get throwing down
your chin every time you think flip
invited how are you eating this maybe
your palate is a little less developed
than mine would you put Nutella on sushi
why not apples why wouldn't you put you
put peaches on pizza how crazy are you
absolutely fine Apple is the greatest
fruit that there is it's tough on the
outside but when you crack that baby
open it's nice and sweet on the inside
just like me
how do you get cracked open and it only
takes about three Bud Lights the only
fruit that goes on is tomatoes and
tomato sauce oh I'm hearing stuff from a
little boy that never dreamed like
olives on your pizza
personally no less is more gang what's
more vanilla Plains stock photo go ahead
flat Italy you tell an Italian their
pizza is boring with just a [ __ ]
piece of basil on there maybe a little
mooks
if I handed you a delicious spear of
pineapple yeah and you were like about
to dig it and I go wait a second I know
what you need some cheese what are you a
monster that's so gross oh boy the bread
dripping to you
hey pizza's fine again where would we be
if we didn't try this oh you should try
a bunch of things but that doesn't mean
every iteration you come up with you go
that's the one this is what happens when
you have [ __ ] pizzerias accessible
pizza the problem please give me a break
portable pizza for all making love doing
different things two different textures
two different everything I would love to
like pineapple on pizza the only problem
is when I put it in my mouth I get sad
you know what happens when you call the
real New York pizza place hello miss
Ruiz how you doing what would you like
on your pizza
pineapple hahaha go [ __ ] yourself I've
supported more pizza restaurants in my
entire life than you ever have I used to
work at a pizza place
nothing says authentic pizza like Tampa
Florida New York style [ __ ] I
know a lot of people alike are big on
like pizza is the sacred thing that you
shouldn't do anything to I don't think
you should put good things on pizza as
opposed to bad ones you're to in
tradition talk to me about some mac and
cheese pizza
let's talk for hours that is fantastic
no too much cheese Oh Chicago and New
Yorkers we disagree on pizza on many
levels but I know one one thing we could
agree on
that pineapple does not go on for in
pizza because New Yorkers are stubborn
I'm from Boston and you can't reason
with New Yorkers that's really were like
it comes to like a cross for me and it's
just does this taste bad it does I serve
all the yes and I know it away I throw
it in the trash because it's garbage in
the trash yeah yeah it's for raccoons
you know who invented the pineapple
pizza a Canadian sin Papadopoulos cleans
oh he creates the first Hawaiian pizza
and Chatham Ontario know what Island of
Hawaii was is Ontario Canada I think
they are capitalizing on pineapple and a
Hawaiian theme to make this horrible lie
I trust Canadians more than I trust the
Italians when it comes to pizza and I
stand by that goddammit you guys hear
this we hear this Canada is great and
there
when it comes to pizza you're being sold
lies you're eating a lie you're really
wearing a Hawaiian shirt yeah because I
think why baby that Florida Sun baked
your brain to mush let's have the
Canadian make a pizza this is fun
in conclusion Tampa with your campus a
little bit too much like a Puritan over
here trying to cute yeah
put any pineapple on pizza as my Jewish
folk would say is a Shanda this is a
little bit different just like people I
feel like we need to accept it you want
whatever you want a pizza cool
fine Nance eat that pie play that
twisted metal till 4:00 in the morning
pineapple pizza it's all built on live
when we look back at the chacras of the
history books staff will be on the wrong
side of history they have already been
written
Amaury on the right side I've had enough
food in my lifetime to know which two
things could tango these two things they
and dancing look how big that fight was
you just watched a mind be changed
look at that well I guess the future
doesn't want it like get off me
you don't order to be able to have you
seen The Parent Trap what's seen when
they're in the cabin together they're
like you like peanut buzz in Oreo
hey Ryan I like your shirt thanks I like
yours too Thanks buy it here